die Thüringer Kreisstadt Sonneberg 1800
Menschen folgen dem Aufruf des afd-nahen
Vereins Sonneberg zeigt Gesicht am
Montagabend der Verein organisiert seit
zwei Jahren schon Proteste in der 23.000
Einwohner statt damals ging es um
corona-maßnahmen und die Impfpflicht nun
geht es um Waffenlieferung an die
Ukraine und die Energiekrise wir haben
[Musik]
eine Bürger
die herrschende politikkaste und ein
Großteil der Medien unterstützt dabei
schädliche narrative im Protestzug offen
dabei die bei reichsbürgern und
rechtsextremen beliebte würmerflagge
Teilnehmer der angeblich
parteifirmenveranstaltungen sind auch
etliche Vertreter der AFD in kleinen und
mittleren Städten versuche die extreme
Rechte so in der Breite anschlussfähig
zu sein als Organisatoren sehen wir hier
viele Akteure der extremen Rechten die
hier auftreten und natürlich
Konjunkturen nutzen wir hatten das mit
der sogenannten flüchtlingskrise wir
hatten das auch mit den der
corona-pandemie die jetzt
emotionalisierte Parolen im Endeffekt
anbieten die Menschen eher ansprechen
als das was die Demokratie anbietet
nämlich ausführliche Erklärung seit
Wochen aber stagnieren die
Teilnehmerzahlen solcher Proteste wie
sich am Montag auch in der Lutherstadt
Wittenberg zeigt mit 2700 Teilnehmern
kamen weit weniger zusammen als erwartet
und das trotz bundesweiter mobil durch
die extreme Rechte Beobachter sehen
darin einen Erfolg der geplanten
Entlastungen waren zugleich aber vor
einer Radikalisierung der Proteste wir
erleben ja das auf diesen
Demonstrationen zum Teil Forderungen
vorgebracht werden die mit dem
thematischen Anlass der Demonstrationen
nichts zu tun haben und die Gefahr ist
schon in der Tat dass wir dann in eine
protestkern Menschen
beobachten wie sich derartig
radikalisieren dass am Ende des Tages
dann eben der Sturz des politischen
Systems propagiert wird auch Gewalt
gegenüber Andersdenkenden propagiert
wurde in den letzten Wochen brennen
wieder Flüchtlingsunterkünfte wie hier
in Groß strömkendorf in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sowie im
sächsischen Bautzen und in Leinefelde in
Thüringen verzichtet der Landkreis auf
den Ausbau einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft
weil es zuvor anonyme Druck schreiben
gab eine Form der Radikalisierung die
auch Thema der Innenminister in Erfurt
sein wird
ja und eingeladen zu diesem Treffen der
ostdeutschen Innenministerin und
Minister hat der thüringische
Innenminister Georg Meier von der SPD
mit ihm können wir jetzt sprechen
schönen guten Morgen nach Friedrichroda
schönen guten Morgen nach Berlin wir
haben es gerade den Beitrag ja gesehen
einer ihrer Landräte hat wegen zwei
drohscheiben eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft
dann doch lieber nicht eingerichtet wo
blieb die Unterstützung der
Landesregierung kapituliert Thüringen
jetzt für rechter Hetze
nein wir kapitulieren nicht und in dem
Fall ganz konkret habe ich auch
Unterstützung angeboten es ging ja auch
darum diese Unterkunft da auch zu
schützen mit Hilfe der Polizei das
hätten wir auch gemacht aber der Landrat
hat halt die Entscheidung so getroffen
das müssen wir es erstmal akzeptieren
ihr Ministerpräsident Bodo Ramelow von
der Linken der warnt vor der Bildung
einer faschistischen Bewegung vor allem
in Ostdeutschland welche Tendenzen
beobachten Sie
ja also ich sehe das auch mit einer
gewissen sorge also man darf jetzt nicht
dramatisieren aber man muss das ernst
nehmen die Demonstrationen in
Ostdeutschland sind deutlich größer und
das hat natürlich auch Gründe was uns
mit Sorge erfüllt und deswegen habe ich
auch die Kollegen der anderen
ostdeutschen Bundesländern mal
eingeladen ist dass das hier eine
Unterwanderung gibt an vielen Orten eine
Instrumentalisierung dieser
Demonstration durch Rechtsextremisten
das demonstriert wird in der Krise ist
völlig normal und gehört zur Demokratie
dazu aber hier gibt es halt Tendenzen
hier versuchen rechtsextreme in die
Gesellschaft einzusickern vorzudringen
entgrenzungen nennt man das und das ist
das Problem weil in der Folge kann es
auch zu einer Radikalisierung einzelner
oder sogar von Gruppen kommen sie sagen
das ist besonders in Ostdeutschland ist
es aber nicht das Problem größer und
müsste das nicht auch größer angegangen
werden als jetzt nur über den
Innenminister der ostdeutschen Länder
das ist richtig aber wir sind nun mal
für Sicherheit zuständig wir sollten
zuallererst uns darüber unterhalten aber
natürlich ist das auch ein
gesellschaftliches Thema schauen Sie die
Situation in Ostdeutschland ist schon
eine andere als im Westen hier sind die
Löhne durchschnittlich geringer die
Vermögen sind viel geringer als im
Westen das heißt eine Krise auszuhalten
ist halt einfacher wenn man Reserven hat
wenn man da auf etwas zurückgreifen kann
ich glaube hier sind soziale Themen die
eine Rolle spielen aber es geht
natürlich auch um das Thema Demokratie
an sich ja wie können wir die Demokratie
stärken wie können wir Einstellungen
aber auch zum Beispiel
verschwörungsmythen die ja auch auf
diesen Demonstrationen
verbreitet werden wie können wir die
zurückdrängen wie können wir stärker
aufklären das ist wie gesagt ein
gesellschaftlicher Aufgabe jetzt haben
sie einige Fragen aufgeworfen wie fällt
denn ihre Antwort darauf aus wie wollen
sie als Politik darauf reagieren
also die Politik reagiert ja ich bin
sehr froh dass die Bundesregierung jetzt
ja weitreichende Maßnahmen angekündigt
hat und das hat schon Wirkung erzielt
aus meiner Sicht die Demonstrationen
sind jetzt von der Teilnehmerzahl wieder
etwas rückläufig und das ist schon mal
ein gutes Zeichen
insbesondere die sozialen Themen müssen
angegangen werden aber natürlich ich als
Innenminister wir als Innenminister
müssen uns die Bereiche angucken wo
Radikalisierung droht und da müssen wir
insbesondere die länderübergreifende
Zusammenarbeit weiter intensivieren weil
das Problem ist ja nicht auf Thüringen
beschränkt oder auf die Demonstrationen
hier sondern das ist ja zum Beispiel in
Sachsen-Anhalt das ist überall so dass
ich hier auch Gruppen herausgebildet
haben die Netzwerke bilden und am Ende
kann es dazu kommen dass sich wie gesagt
es zu Radikalisierung kommt die Sprache
die Verrohung auf diesen Demonstrationen
die kann man ja sehen wie kann man hören
und der Schritt zur Gewalt ist halt
gegebenenfalls nicht mehr so weit
experten gehen jetzt davon aus dass
unter Umständen eher noch mehr
geflüchtete jetzt gab es bei der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz schon mal
Zusagen vom Bund aber glauben Sie dass
Sie damit jetzt sage ich mal über den
Winter kommen
also ich höre aus der kommunalen Familie
eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit ich kann
das jetzt wie soll ich sagen als
Innenminister jetzt ich bin nicht für
Migration zuständig nicht weiter
kommentieren es ist wichtig dass der
Bund jetzt erstmal unterstützt ob das
reicht bleibt man dahin gestellt weil es
ist schon eine sehr sehr große Aufgabe
jetzt gerade für die Kommunen für die
Kreise hier müssten weiter Unterkünfte
beschafft werden weil die Wohnung sind
jetzt so weitgehend weg und wir müssen
natürlich auch dafür Sorge tragen dass
diese Unterkünfte geschützt werden weil
wir leider feststellen müssen dass in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und in Sachsen
ist schon Angriffe gab also hier muss
beides zusammenkommen finanzielle
Unterstützung aber auch natürlich
Sicherheit von Seiten der
Sicherheitsbehörden dann sagte
Innenminister Thüringens Georg Maier von
der SPD vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit